okay glass
record a video
[Music]
looking at you through the glass watch
me running in the grass
oh god but i feel like a weirdo but no
one ever tells you that the weirdos feel
at home
wearing glass alone on top their head
how does it feel that is the question
but don't forget that you can google
stupid questions
when something like a time becomes
unknown to you just lift your head to
activate say okay glass what time is
that event
so while you're outside looking in
tweeting what you see
remember what you're sharing is a feat
oh i'm looking at you through the glass
now i'm checking out my ass oh god but i
feel like a weirdo but no one ever tells
you that the weirdos feel at home
wearing google glass alone on top their
there
[Music]
[Applause]